foreign
a couple weeks ago I got an email asking
to review a literal casket
[Music]
into ridiculous yeah but the point is I
get all kinds of crazy stuff in my inbox
all the time some of it's Tech but some
of it's not even Tech I say no to
literally 99 of the things I get asked
but what if
just for fun I said yes
to everything
so I did for a whole month I said yes to
everything in my inbox including this
beautiful casket so the story behind why
it's this casket is this is the model of
casket that Taylor Swift popped out of
in the anti-hero music video yeah that
one right there that one is a Titan
Orion series casket then after this
video came out there were a bunch of
stories about how Taylor Swift
accidentally became the face of the
funeral industry for a second so the
story is that the company Titan caskets
actually has a pretty noble cause so you
might not know this but the funeral
industry most of the companies making
funeral equipment are selling it to
funeral homes who then package it all up
and sell it to the customer sort of like
a middleman that's how you end up
getting his huge markups and paying five
ten thousand dollars for a casket so
Titan now is the fastest growing direct
to Consumer casket company in the US
selling direct to Consumer cutting out
the middleman is how you end up with
this 1299 casket the Orion from a Taylor
Swift music video much better uh also
once that showed up in the music video
they added the code Swifty at checkout
and so you get like 50 bucks off it's a
pretty killer deal anyway that is why
they were in my inbox not because it's
like some high-tech casket or anything
like that it's actually a very normal
high quality steel casket with a locking
mechanism and rubber gaskets The
Innovation isn't necessarily with the
casket itself although
it is pretty comfortable for a gasket
anyway
let's see what else came in okay so this
is a headset for your headset it's
called The Conquest VR the idea here
being you have a VR headset and you put
this on you're in the game but if you
want to do audio you need either earbuds
or a headset to go on top of it which
isn't exactly ideally designed
and so this is a 200 high-res audio
solution to clip onto the VR headset so
now here's here's where you end up
you're in here
ah
obviously it's much better to have a
lightweight headset that's not adding
extra weight
and uh yeah that's what it does so
overall I'm tempted to give these like a
7 out of ten like they work and the idea
is that they would pair and and work
with the game and not be extra
cumbersome but they're 200 or 179
currently and for that you can get a
nice set of wireless headphones that are
pretty lightweight and not have to risk
it with these so
seven okay this is uh by a company
called ranvu it is a portable air
conditioner and heater
for yourself
this is the portable air conditioner
it's called the medara the idea is
there's fans and batteries inside and
you pick a temperature and you turn it
on and you put it around your neck I
have found it to work pretty well there
is an app for it that you have to
download and install which is not ideal
and then
an air conditioning mode right now there
you go here this is the maximum
oh that's a breeze right there you hear
that right just the bottom of my ears
chilling
oh that's now it's in heating mode and
it's it's blowing warm air now so that's
the thing it can do so it has a 5800
milliamp hour battery and it costs
250 dollars I'm trying to think of why
it would cost this much like yeah it can
heat and cool but like you could get a
scarf dang it is warm it's nice that it
can get actually warm but I don't see
this being better than just like wearing
a
scarf I'm gonna give this a 5 out of 10
because it works it's just not a good
use of money that's not the only thing
this company sent they also sent this
this is ranvu's electronic uh hand
warmer um I'm glad it's this color
there's a tiny LCD screen that tells you
your temperature hopefully nobody's
judging you too hard because you are the
warmest who 81 battery you're the
warmest person on the bus this is also
like a red flag that it's so hard to
find their website uh 4 000 milliamp
hour battery oh this is like a this is
like a you can buy a bunch it's a
wholesale price 80 bucks I feel like
this logo looks a little too similar to
the Apple news logo five out of 10. okay
these pretty simple
[Music]
cases and I said we're doing customized
cases send us your memoji I sent one of
me and I sent one of Mac
and these are the case sexy
customized memoji clear plastic cases
that you get as a result take the
plastic out I don't know
that's what you end up with you get a
nice little case sexy watermark on the
corner of your case it might not be the
highest quality thing in the world but I
guess mission accomplished
[Music]
you
this is not the first case that I would
pick here's the other thing when you put
a magsafe case on a phone you're
supposed to get the little animation
then you plug it in and it's official
magsafe accessory you can still magsafe
charge your phone with this on but it is
not uh giving The Full magsafe
Experience I'll just put it that way
does what it says it's supposed to do
which is say it's your face on a case
thumbs up but yeah as far as build
quality and
whether or not I would get it I'm
leaning like let's go three out of ten
okay this this is uh this one actually
is sort of interesting to me
here's the price 250 right now on their
website and it's basically a seven inch
touchscreen that becomes the
infotainment system in your car it's
clearly meant to be for older cars that
don't have an infotainment system we've
tried it it has some pros and cons right
so you do have to plug it in both into
power and into the audio jack in your
car if it has one there are other
methods of connecting it to your car as
well
suction cup mount to put it up in your
dash on the user manual here it shows
that it works with Apple carplay and
Android auto now when you actually fire
it up and use it it shows a auto and
iPlay I actually think it's kind of
solid it adds functionality to your car
right so this is a backup camera that
can see in the dark with an LED light
you put this on the back of your car and
you find a way to wire this all the way
up to the front of your car and plug it
in and now
you have a backup camera it's fine for
200 250 bucks like you don't have to buy
a whole new car you get most of the
functionality you can listen to music
from your phone you basically just have
to face the challenge of like how
exactly do you connect it to your older
car yeah I'm gonna go eight out of ten
solid all right
so I I say yes to a lot of phones right
I review a lot of phones on this channel
I you know there's only so many things
we can possibly cover and actually use
so there's plenty that we also say no to
this one it's a it's a real me phone
you've seen realme phones before but as
you can tell by this absurd looking box
it's a bit of a collab I just picture
the meeting that I had which was like oh
yeah how are we going to break into the
US market we really need to get some
more real new phones in the hands of us
customers
I have just the idea so here's this is
the phone I'll get to that in a second
but it also came with uh the real me cat
again so the roomy 10 Pro is actually a
pretty good phone it's a nice budget
phone Snapdragon 695 120hz display 5 000
milliamp hour battery with 33 watt
charging 108 megapixel camera but again
this isn't just any normal realme 10 Pro
it's the half Coca-Cola realme 10 Pro it
just keeps going here's the uh
oh my God it's a sticker pack in the top
and then you get the phone itself which
you're never gonna believe this but
it says Coca-Cola gigantic across the
back of your phone I like red and black
so like a little part of me is like yeah
that's kind of nice but on the other
hand you are a billboard now for the
Coca-Cola phone that's what this is and
it keeps going you turn on the phone
I'll show you the footage of this but
like the wallpaper included is Coca-Cola
the icon packs included are Coca-Cola
the sounds that come out of the phone
for like the touch sounds and the
ringtone are like Coca-Cola bottle
sounds
stuff
you didn't have to go this hard I don't
even drink Coca-Cola I don't even like
it but I gotta have a little bit of
respect for the fact that they they did
go absolutely to 11 with this collab so
I'm giving an 11. it's an 11 out of 10.
this is the best brand collab I've seen
in a really long time even if I would
never buy it we see a lot of headphones
come through here a lot of earbuds this
pair is uh is called it's from
gravastar.com which it says on the case
and they're called the Sirius p5s
they're 80 bucks and they're like a
fairly normal set of earbuds they have a
ipx4 40 hour battery life electronic
noise cancellation they have a
surprising amount of gimmicks uh to them
for the 80 bucks I have a sweater
screwdriver here and you'll see why in a
second first of all this is the case
this might be the strongest
spring-loaded case I've ever seen in
earbuds you also notice there's lights
on the back of them and lights on the
back of the case so when they're
charging it lights up green to let you
know it's charging the earbuds
themselves they kind of just look like
normal old matte black air pods but
they're like heavy and metallic and they
don't really stay in my ears so I would
never be able to use these because
it's just not possible so
that's kind of a problem for me here's
the other gimmick though here's the
shtick right and the case within a case
can actually come out of this
and go into a different Design This one
being metal Chomper here so what you got
to do unscrew
this Flathead screw
and sure enough
this whole thing
just pops right out and then you put
this tray inside of a different case
like maybe this one but this like
customization thing with earbuds you
don't really see very much especially in
the ones we tend to look at which are
likes this Sony is the pixel buds the
airpods that are all sort of locked in
they don't sound great and they don't
stay in my ears so again I can't use
them I'm gonna give this
a seven
[Music]
all right this one's pretty simple this
is a walkie-talkie read of this we
didn't actually own walkie-talkies and
it actually will turn out to be quite
useful for us in car shoots but
initially this company reached out and
said hey we've got these radio frequency
transmitters
and I it's like yeah I'm saying yes to
everything so yeah here's the shipping
address and their response was okay
perfect do you have a license for this
one I said no I don't think I do I
didn't want to have to go get a license
so they they suggested a lower power
model instead we ended up with this uh
very out very functional
walkie-talkie uh multi-channel it's got
the little belt loop it's got an antenna
I believe Andrew's in the other room
with the other one paging Andrew come in
Astro do a dance then for it
recalibrating the idea is uh it works
which is basically all I could ask I
literally don't know what else to ask of
a walkie-talkie other than how far can
it go so I'll put the number on screen
for what they say this will do right
there Astro Play Never Gonna Give You Up
by Rick Astley I'm currently giving up
next all right last but not least
uh you've always wanted to have a
multi-screen laptop this company reached
out and they make a multi-screen
laptop
setup you just use your own laptop as a
middle screen and then they make the two
other screens that plug into it it's
kind of incredible I've set this up
we've gotten it to work unfold it like
that this is what the contraption looks
like it's a lot of plastic and hinges
and then a display on each side and then
it comes with a bunch of cables in here
so if I were to use something like this
this 16 inch MacBook Pro which it's
actually perfectly sized for with these
other two screens you would literally
just
pop it over the top like this you can
see it adjusts in size it folds around
the laptop screen you plug all the
screens in
and as your multiple displays it is it's
kind of cool I'm not even gonna lie
these are each 16 inch displays with a
Max refresh rate of 144 Hertz they're
2560 by 1800 LED IPS they're not bad
they also have an anti-glare surface so
they kind of match decently with the
Macbook Pro not perfectly it currently
works with Mac OS right now they're
planning windows in quarter one 2023 so
that may work soon it accomplishes the
goal nine out of 10. so what have we
learned well I actually have some
learnings from all of this saying yes to
pass along to you and for myself so I'm
of course in a very fortunate place
where I can pull this off where I just
say yes to a bunch of stuff in my inbox
and some really cool Tech actually shows
up at the studio but it did shed some
light on the experience for other
potential creators see I tried to say
yes to everything but I actually wasn't
able to end up with everything here at
the studio see a lot of smaller
companies that reach out and want some
reviews to happen of their products they
have a small allotment of products that
they get to give out for reviews and so
when they send something out they want
to really make sure that they're getting
a video out of it and so a lot of them
will try to make sure they can guarantee
a video from the Creator that they're
emailing or even make you sign a
contract saying that you will make a
video on the thing if you receive it
creators don't sign those I did say at
the beginning of that I say no to 99 of
things
and at the end of the day that's a
really good problem to have
I'm glad this challenge is over
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one peace
[Music]